hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Plato has Socrates speak at many points
in different dialogues about the nature
of life and death and how we should
understand them how we should evaluate
them what weight we want to give
considerations of danger for your life
and death when it comes to moral
decision-making figuring out the larger
structure of our life all those sorts of
big-picture questions and in the apology
he has Socrates talked at several points
about why it is that that he's not
afraid to die and this makes great sense
because he's on trial for his life
actually some of that is not the best
approach rhetorically unless his unless
he already sort of knows that they're
probably going to convict him and he
wants to make some points because he
does say in a few points you know you
guys in the audience you might actually
bring your kids out and have them cry
and trying to sway the the jury's
opinions I'm not going to do that kind
of thing because I'm not actually afraid
of death you guys who are afraid of
death there's something wrong with your
thinking about this that's not going to
win over anybody but it does make some
really important points now you notice
that I've got
here there are some things that we know
are bad and so Socrates is going to talk
about that when we're doing moral
decision-making or when we're talking
about matters of life and death we need
to know how much weight to give each
consideration and so some things we
actually Socrates says some things we
actually do have knowledge about when it
comes to moral matters I know that in
parts of this dialogue it kind of sounds
as if he's wise because he knows that he
doesn't know anything but he does say I
do know some things and those things
tend to be these moral matters that
he'll repeat over and over again the
other thing that goes into this is
according to Socrates you know the s--
really perhaps according to Plato we
don't really know what death is whether
it's a good thing or a bad thing you
could say that you know Socrates is is
sort of preaching to the audience that
he's got at the time because he does in
fact in other dialogues talk about you
know life after death life before death
so presumably he actually does endorse
one of these options but when he's
talking to the members of the jury
particularly after they've convicted him
and the people who convicted him have
left and the other people who voted for
him are still there and are pretty upset
he brings out these considerations so
this comes up early on though he says
one reason why we shouldn't be afraid of
death one reason why I'm not afraid of
death is because that would be
pretending to have wisdom that I don't
actually have now you can say that the
the human body has a sort of natural
fear of pain of destruction of sickness
violence and therefore of death but we
don't know whether the body's impulses
the body's sort of unconscious or
instinctual evaluations are actually on
track and if part of what it means to be
a human being is to be able to decide
for oneself to think things through for
once
then if we don't really know what death
is strictly speaking if we were being
completely rational we can't say yeah
it's something to be feared the Socrates
doesn't know that it is something to be
feared and this is really what we need
to give greater weight to are these
things over here and you notice I've got
two different classes of things so one
of the points that he makes is he says I
don't know if death is a bad thing I do
know that this is a bad thing for me to
do bad things and you know for example
when I was stationed as a soldier in the
Athenian army defending a city at this
battle or that battle I knew that it was
right for me to stay at my post and to
fight and to take you know the chance of
getting killed I knew that it would be
wrong for me to throw away my shield and
take off for home it's wrong to lie it's
wrong to deceive people it's wrong to
you know commit violence against them
it's wrong to damage people in such ways
that you make them worse off morally
Socrates does quite a few things that he
thinks are right and things that are
wrong and doing philosophy he says look
this this lifestyle that I have is
actually a obligation that I've got on
me that is a divine mission I've got a
you know discussion about that on
another core concept and it's also a
benefit to you guys the Athenians I'm
actually a great benefactor to you by by
doing this because I'm calling your
attention to what really matters your
souls this is what I was supposed to be
doing I would be doing wrong if I were
to say just to save my life I'm gonna
stop doing that I would be abandoning my
post and I know that that's wrong so
that therefore that has to have greater
weight we could say the same thing if he
was put in a situation where if he
thought that lying was just you know
simply wrong where he's being compelled
to lie or or lose his life Socrates
could buy this
same sort of argument or same sort of
logic say I don't know whether it's a
bad thing to lose my life I do know that
it's a bad thing a very bad thing to lie
so I'm gonna accept losing my life now
there are other penalties that are
possible so this is the second thing
here there are other penalties that are
possible for him that he could have
actually accepted or suggested he does
actually in the end suggest a fine after
of course telling them really you know
what I do deserve is free room and board
from the Athenian people the rest of my
life but he's kind of joking around with
that exile
why would exile be a bad thing isn't it
the opportunity to travel well you know
Socrates says look I'm an old man my
roots are here in this community if
they're not willing to let me do
philosophy here in Athens they're
probably not going to be too keen on me
doing it in in Sparta or colophon or
thieves or pick wherever else you want
so I'm not going to be able to do what I
need to do you notice there's sort of a
connection between those things prison
he says that's not the way I want to
live the rest of my life prison is
indeed an evil and I would like to be
able to come and go and do the sorts of
things that I've been doing for the last
you know decades in in the city of
Athens that would definitely be a bad
thing
paying a fine he says well you know
that's basically the same thing as
prison anyway because I don't have any
money so if you want me to pay a fine
I'm not going to be able to to pay it
and I'll have to sit in prison until I
die if somebody comes up with the ransom
so these are things that he says are
worth avoiding even at the cost of death
because we know that these are bad
things let's now turn to this issue of
well what is death we don't know whether
it's a good or bad thing unless we
actually know what death is
and Socrates at this point is saying we
don't know under what death is but he is
willing to speculate a bit
so he says look it could be one of two
things and the first one is actually two
things by itself in a way if you sort of
parse it out but he doesn't really
believe that one anyway
he's just preferring that to the jury
saying if you buy this sort of idea
about death and you know don't grieve
for me
maybe it's annihilation maybe it's the
total cessation of one's life maybe
there's nothing of oneself after one
dies maybe the body is all there is this
is very much along the lines of the view
of the Epicureans who are going to come
a little bit later and you know there's
many other people who've made similar
arguments if that's the case if death is
just annihilated then there's no you who
is being harmed or for whom it's a bad
thing when the death actually happens
it's kind of a non-event
it's a all the events of your life
coming to an end and and no longer
existing or it could be he talks about
it may imagine the best night's sleep
that you ever had totally restful you
didn't wake up didn't even dream
anything made it's just like that for
all eternity
and there there's still be something
existing but it's in this this
essentially comatose state and never
does anything never thinks anything it's
not really that far away from
annihilation but it is something
different from it he says the same thing
holds for that you know if that's the
case then you know anything to be
concerned about afterwards right
nobody's gonna wake you up
you're not going to have indigestion in
the middle of the night you're not gonna
have a bad dream that you know you get
caught in and can't get out of so in
that case death would actually be a good
thing or at least not a bad thing that
he says maybe it's a change of place now
here a lot more could be said about the
relationship of Plato's views of the
after life in relation to sort of the
mishmash of traditional Greek
conceptions of the afterlife that we get
in the poets and plays and you know
Greek religion as it was practiced but
they did have a conception of the
afterlife as a place where judgment
would take place and the fate of a
person would be you know decided
according to some sort of criteria and
you might go to a good place you might
go to a bad place
it really depends on which poet you're
reading if it's Homer of course better
to be a poor labourer alive than to be
the king of the dead is what achilles
says down in Hades to Odysseus what he
goes down there so that's not quite so
so nice but the way that Socrates frames
it is let's say the traditional Greek
religion is actually on track and
remember he's addressing a jury that
that isn't all plate nests so they don't
all believe in this you know endless you
know migration of souls
only you know ceasing when you finally
get off the thing through being purified
the way that it talks about the fate of
later on
instead they think of it as going
somewhere being judged and now he says
I'll die here and these are bad judges
who are actually judging me but they're
I'm gonna have true judges I'm gonna get
vindicated I'm going to be judged by my
toes and Redman thoughts and you know
maybe the gods who knows these are these
legendary incorruptible judges in the
underworld even more interesting he says
you know what there's one thing that
they won't be able to do in the
afterlife that they can do here and
that's to kill me to shut me up because
I'll get to go you know I did this
entire life that I've been here I've
been you know asking what is virtue who
actually has virtue who's got wisdom
I've been cross-examining people now
I'll get to do it with the dead so if
homers down there
instead of asking you know Homer
scholars or raps ODEs
what did Homer mean by this or thinking
about it by myself I can go up to the
guy and he asked it myself and and you
know I could get get a hold of them and
not let go until he has fully answered
all of my questions if I want to know
about Achilles well he'll be down there
too I can go and and chat with him you
get this image of Socrates buttonholing
people and just being kind of a general
pest in the underworld for he's he's
dead who preceded him and probably all
the ones that would come afterwards - oh
you're here maybe you're wise lobby talk
with you well that's the way that he
presents it and if that's the case then
death is actually a good thing
if you're a good person if you're a bad
person then you know these incorruptible
judges you may have gotten by by bribing
judges in this life or you know finding
some evidence on that and blackmailing
them but you're not going to do that
with these guys and the other Dead
probably aren't going to like you if
you're kind of a schmuck maybe you're in
the other dead who are bad people won't
like you either here we're getting very
speculative
in any case Socrates is saying death is
not a bad thing first time we don't know
whether it's a good thing or bad thing
and that second if we start making
assumptions about it it starts to look
like it's a good thing
third we know that there are some bad
things that are worth taking into
consideration that we want to avoid
rather than trying to avoid death